journalism is under attack
like never before no gas fire you have
to have the fact
beautiful but tragic because people are
doubting everything
you're the only way of telling their
story how would you describe this
outbreak something like an apocalypse
you're gonna be
really tired you're gonna be really
scared it's too dangerous
anyone who says they're not scared is
life anything
can happen did you get here i sometimes
wonder how have we managed to get out of
this we do
genuinely believe in what we do he's
clearly martial press
to show the truth wow this is absolutely
unbelievable to uncover
an injustice this is the result of
ethnic cleansing
i don't think any journalist wants
anything more than that i'm alex
crawford
i'm stuart ramsey and this is hot spots
god bless america thank you very much
i accept this nomination i have no idea
how i ended up covering the u.s election
because i
definitely didn't have any experience to
draw on
we condemn in the strongest possible
terms
this egregious display of hatred bigotry
and violence on many sides today once
again
we are a house divided but the bosses
thought this was going to be a momentous
election whatever happened we're still
in the battle for the soul of america
a vote for biden is a vote for lockdowns
layoffs and misery
vote like this country depends on it
because it does
i don't have a great appetite for
working on a political story in the
united states
except when you've got an incredible
story like this one day it's like a
miracle it will disappear due to donald
trump's lies and confidence in the past
six months have seen one of the greatest
losses of american life in history
the turmoil caused by
the covid outbreak the divisions in the
country
the background of the black lives matter
and the rioting that had taken place
the two sides were so polarized and the
two
political parties and their supporters
were so polarized
it was going to be a big big story
whatever happened it was going to be
momentous
what did you vote for today i voted for
a guy named trump
thank you very much everybody the
countdown stands at six days
from november third georgia election
officials are warning that the lines at
the polling places could start to get
longer during this final stretch of
early voting friday
is the last date to cast an early ballot
i had a couple of conversations with
alex before she came to america
it's not her patch and she's used to
covering very different stories
and she said i think we should start off
in georgia because i have a feeling
georgia is going to be interesting i
think it's going to be
closer than anyone thinks the reason
georgia was interesting is because of
voter suppression and we wanted to go
and investigate
whether or not we were seeing evidence
of that
so we managed to get in with a group
called black voters mata
so if you see people that don't have nas
give them a mouse okay it was pretty
inspiring meeting all these
invariably young mostly african-american
volunteers talk to them right tell them
about the importance of voting
i want to just tell y'all why your work
is so
important you were really fired up black
voters are tapering off so we need to
really make
a final push a hard push right we can't
afford for
our community to sit out this election
it was like listening to an
army general or an army major preparing
the troops for battle
all right let's go get this work
she's the politician in the family
tell me a couple of examples of the way
votes could be
suppressed voter id laws making it hard
for people
to vote after the 2010 election
thousands of black voters were removed
from this district that should never
happen
and they kept on stressing we don't say
which party to vote for
but we just want people to vote
there was also a really deep keen sense
of injustice because two years earlier
an investigation discovered that there
were tens of thousands
of mainly african americans who'd been
disenfranchised
so you're not trying to target the
republican voters
they because when we do you see the guy
the guy with the shirt off
he just told us to get the elf out of
his neighborhood wow
and he got trump everything and what did
you say to him in return
i see you okay do you feel intimidated
when something like that happens
i don't you feel worried i don't angry
i don't what do you feel strength
it gives me strength being in the deep
south there's a real history of racism
and division and segregation stemming
from slavery
i found the whole racism thing
absolutely staggering this whole
election certainly in that moment in
that state
in that town was just boiled down to
color and race something that america
has been
dealing with for decades
i think there's a joke that i don't
normally do peaceful transitions of
power
and i think what made this one was
interesting it was it sort of became a
sort of odds-on favorite
that this might not be an orderly and
peaceful transition of power this is the
third
night of unrest following the shooting
death of walter wallace
by philadelphia police officers in
philadelphia another black man was shot
by
the police i think at about four in the
morning
i got a phone call saying hi dominique
sorry to wake you
um but we need you guys to go to
philadelphia
please yeah i mean it was a real it was
a real rush job
i think um i think we had two hours to
get up get rid of the car
deliver the car back to the car rental
company and get on the plane
and which we've done well not much fun
there had been two nights of
demonstrations that had turned violent
and the call was through for us to go
there as quickly as possible
unrest continued in our city in reaction
to the death of 27-year-old walter
wallace
jr shot and killed by police officers we
knew that we were going to a very
different story in philadelphia
and as soon as we drove into
philadelphia
uh you could feel the tension and the
pulse of that city
race is obviously a really hot topic and
a very sensitive
topic in america
the whole race issue had become a
massive factor within
the election the black lives matter
movement
the numbers of black men mainly but not
entirely
shot dead by the police but that night
the city authorities imposed a curfew
and nobody really knew whether people
would observe it or not
simply by seeing police officers in
full-ride gear armed
is it automatically makes people feel
tense about a situation
we could feel that sense there's that
there's that electricity in the air that
you you get when something is
just on the verge of kicking off well
tension between some police forces and
some communities in the united states
have been getting worse for months
you can see they're not taking any
chances here they're out in force and
this is actually to protect
their own precinct building but what
really amazed us was going from street
corner to street corner to street corner
to street corner just
just hundreds and hundreds of police
officers pre-deployed
you know i've covered a lot of riots so
you've got to make a guess as to where
they're going to be
but in this particular instance it's
difficult to gauge because
we just had to have time to really get
to the bottom of what was going on or
where or when or why
you must disperse the area
and you will be arrested this is your
final warning
it wasn't really busy with people but
the people that were there were angry
and we were picking up some shots
and then we just spotted some guys just
out of our vision and just out of the
the main
say crowd why one of them said
they were a relative of uh walter
wallace they didn't junior they didn't
want to say in what capacity
but they explained very succinctly why
it was that
this had turned into what it had turned
to on the street
training is lacked in the philadelphia
police department
that car should have had a social worker
or somebody the equivalent of a social
worker that worked for the police
department
talked this man down he did not have to
get shot
14 times they said it feels like the
police are more scared
of black guys with a knife or with a gun
than there are a white guys with a gun
or knife because they're fascists
that's why is this america is this what
america is now
because it was a it was a visceral
division
there was quite a lot that had grown
from sort of increasing
tensions over race in the united states
and there was always that indicator that
they would play at least a factor
in the election
president trump was back in metro
detroit today his second stop in our
area in the past 72 hours
with election day just two days away
we bounced from georgia to michigan a
bit of a gear change
do you want to face the car facing out
yeah
we'd heard that there were several
hundred militia groups
in america there's a group called the
boogaloo boys
which operates across the states
boogaloo is a movement of people that
are anti-government anti-authority
and say that they're fighting to protect
civilians
and be ready for a civil war should that
break out
and i wanted to get in touch with them
and find out what their thinking was
what their motivation was
because i knew they would be very
different to the people we just
spoken to in georgia i call us patriots
we the boogaloo boys believe the
constitution should be upheld to the
letter
and how far are you prepared to go to
preserve that constitution i am prepared
to do nothing unless somebody else does
something first
it is important as an american passed
down by the knowledge of our forefathers
from their experiences that we always
have to have the contingency plan
to make sure freedom and liberty never
falls into the wrong hands
do you feel it is now i feel it is on
its way and i feel it's been on its way
for a long time
how far are you prepared to go to defend
those freedoms i mean i will never
attack but
i will stand in the way of the enemy if
they make them my enemy
there is a very old cliche one person's
terrorist is another person's freedom
fighter
get a handgun a defense of myself
shotgun defense in my property
or i can get a rifle for depends on my
state yeah we're gonna all line up and
shoot that green bed
i'm not into guns so walking into a gun
shop
never feels very comfortable to me
seeing people kind of trying out the
size of a gun and
how it feels in their hand and whether
they can put it in their handbag easily
or whether they want some huge thing to
keep in their home and many first-time
buyers
um yeah just a boatload of them and they
come in and they don't even know the
process they don't even know what they
have to do all they know is they want to
buy a gun
can you show us the most popular gun
that's that you sell
uh this is gonna be the number one gun
i'm selling right now right here
what is that this is a glock it's called
a glock 19. it's a nine millimeter
handgun
that was a real eye-opener it's the sort
of casual acceptance that
everyone has guns or should have guns
it's almost like a deterrent more than
anything else my goal is to never ever
have to use it
people are doing things that we've never
even thought about doing before
taking it to limits that we've never
thought about going before
well the gun shop owner was very keen
to stress how safe guns were
well you've never shot a gun before
right okay nothing bad is going to
happen
take your finger off the trigger there
you go focusing on this sight pitcher
i want you to pull the trigger slow
jeez not powerful that's not
it's not you're okay it seemed quite
powerful to me i wanted to
get a sense of how easy it was because i
thought i'm just the same as a lot of
these
other women who are picking up guns for
the first time
it's not gonna hurt you keep shooting
it shooting very very well
horribly easy i think to shoot a gun
without any experience and devastatingly
easy
it seemed to me to get it wrong oh
nothing to it
give me a headache that is powerful
very powerful yeah
put your finger on the trigger and pull
the trigger
slow slow
no i didn't enjoy shooting the gun
i wouldn't let you do it watch yourself
i didn't find it exhilarating
i found it a very sobering moment and i
felt uncomfortable
after i had shut the gun and kind of
wanted to put it down and get out of
there really
it doesn't quite feel right it seemed to
me like
handing deadly weapons to beginners is
probably not
a surefire way to keep the peace really
where to the airport
and then from there we're going to uh uh
uh portland oregon we're going we're
going the furthest possible distance
from the tip of the east coast to the
pretty much to the west coast
we got very very little notice it was
about
there that we were all starting to feel
the trip
was starting to wear on us a little bit
another city
in oregon you have until 8 pm tomorrow
to drop off your ballot at an official
drop-off site it's too late to mail it
in oregon
portland is a very
chilled out city uh it couldn't have
been
more different to philadelphia
we were really struck by how amazingly
beautiful it was and also how
cool and libertarian it was
[Music]
and then we started seeing the homeless
and it was like
you've got to be kidding me
there was homeless people everywhere
this isn't just homeless people
wondering about there's a ten cities
outside five five-star hotels
it was the one city that
really started to hit home that america
compared to how i'd seen it before had
really taken a knock
as a society
it's the final hours before election day
and the candidates are in an all-out
battle crisscrossing battleground
states
michigan we were headed to dc
to be in place for election day having
covered
an election in america i know how hard
they can be
and i wasn't overly uh excited at the
prospect of doing it again
um they're bloody hard work look at the
shops all boarded up
jesus they're expecting a bit of a rock
here
you know in the past you've seen
american towns and
areas preparing for natural disasters
like a hurricane's going to come through
having been in america for six years the
last four years i've definitely seen
that there's a lot more angst and
a lot of discontent and so much division
which is making people kind of go at
each other
so we're down the street from lafayette
square which is where
this protest is supposed to kick off
tomorrow
and beyond that is the white house
actually it's quite weird that tomorrow
is finally election day
after like such a crazy build up to it
but we don't really know what's going to
happen
good morning if you haven't turned your
ballot in yet in oregon or washington
you're in the minority voter turnout was
already
really high before yesterday and today
well over
2016 numbers elections officials only
expect those numbers to shoot up
over the next several hours where are we
what are we doing
portland oregon it's uh
it's been lovely the last couple days
and now it's what it's meant to be which
is basically cloudy and white
that's polling day so everyone's quite
excited i think
i don't know if we'll get a result today
first of all we went around
uh various streets trying to pick
places that would normally be popular
and try to pick up people on the street
and speak to them but
no one was out part of that was a part
lockdown
due to cover 19 people just staying at
home working from home
there's nobody at that polling station
but there has been a 70 turnout so far
so
maybe everyone's voted already brain's
not helping foreign
thank you very much that was making the
whole election process a very very
difficult different experience
for the united states and for us as well
we were just not used to this
we've been driving around in pouring
rain for the last few hours trying to
find
some of the big polling stations this is
one a lot of people here
and long queues and long lines and who
did you vote for
i vote for trump why particularly trump
um because i believe that
we should keep the guns with people and
i'm a christian and it seems like he's a
christian
and it's like the right choice one thing
about working in the states that i did
discover i liked is
that when you go to talk to people
people are very willing to to talk to
you
openly and express their opinions and
views and it's it's
quite refreshing um compared to say
somewhere like the uk where people are a
little more reserved on that kind of
thing
i believe in the things that he stands
for i believe in the right to life
i believe in a lot of what he's done
for our country i believe in him
supporting the police and the military
and yeah what was beginning to
surprise us that definitely in talking
to people
it was going to be close and again we
found the same thing the slit between
republican and democrat voting for
donald trump or joe biden so
almost every city we were going to
we had seen that it was going to be
really really close who will you be
voting for if i may ask
i'm still hoping to win on that right
now yeah
it's whoever feels right once i get in
there so you really
undecided right to the end yeah now
that's amazing
because in this uh in the country at the
moment finding people
undecided is quite difficult yeah
i i don't know it's still a really hard
choice for me and my opinion
uh i don't know i i want to see
change but it's biting the right choice
i don't know
it goes to prove a really good point
about journalism
you see if you don't go you don't know
it's as simple as that and the more time
we spend out
the more we were able to say i don't
care what the new york times is saying i
don't care what the washington post is
saying
because that is not what we're finding
a massive rally will be held tonight in
black lives matter plaza near the white
house
and work crews spent the night erecting
a fence around the white house complex
one that's set to remain in place until
at least sunday morning
in addition all d.c police officers will
be on duty this election day
so normally i don't see any other
journalists
or tv crews i'm getting a bit
reporter intimidation
and there was every channel that you
could think of from
every different country in the world you
know as you walked past it was speaking
spanish
french english german
arabic all of them all gathered outside
the white house
[Applause]
put a lot of resource into covering this
election it's a really
big operation over 120 people
uh were in the united states covering
this election don't worry about account
here i'll do it 20 seconds
there's a lot of people but the united
states is huge and you have the time
zones as well
so you've got to basically follow the
rules that are set down and in this case
master control is going to be in
washington dc this was a very different
experience for our team because we're
used to being fairly autonomous and
suddenly we had to
fit into this huge machine and we were
going to be really small cogs
within it when you work for a 24-hour
news station and you've got a story
that's moving constantly
you resort to having reporters in
locations
who every hour will come up and talk
about what's going on and try to bring
the viewing public up to speed with
developments
[Applause]
[Music]
producers and directors they will give
you
a preemptive warning that we're coming
to you in 15 minutes
when they know they're not going to come
to you in about 20 for
20 minutes or 25 minutes or maybe even
half an hour
there's such a machine that is behind
the people that you see on air you know
it's the
camera operators it's the sound
operators it's the producers when you
see
a presenter on the air there are at
least two to three
other people behind them putting them on
air
three and two one zero
q dermot tonight america decides
we're live right across the country in
the states and with the people
whose votes will decide this election
well it's crazy having the earpiece
especially when you're
trying to i don't know how the
presenters do it our special
correspondent alex crawford is right
here in washington where
a big blm rally is taking place this
evening and
alex we can hear it from up here what's
going on on the ground
well at the moment so far it's been a
very much a carnival atmosphere
you can see behind here what should be
one of the most recognizable sites in
america it's the white house i've got in
my ears someone saying
um can you wrap up or can you move over
or can you
frame up a little bit you're someone who
looks fairly familiar
and i'm listening to a person that i'm
interviewing so i've got that going on
we'll be keeping you in touch with what
happens throughout the night but so far
a very jolly atmosphere i don't know how
anyone else does it but i find it
really quite hard well thanks
absolutely on a knife edge anything can
happen in the next
couple of hours all the indicators are
there that this could be nasty there's
armed people
lots of people in body armor who would
put ours on there as well
i foreign
[Music]
although it was a blm march there were
people from
absolutely every different background
the security
for it was you know huge i know people
in america are using guns
on the night that the results were
coming through you had this really
passionate march going through the city
we want change we want change
and you were seeing in real time whether
there was going to be
the change they wanted or not
[Music]
they're surrounded around everywhere we
go by men with weapons
all of the side streets are closed off
it started to become clear within
two or three hours that it was going to
be far closer than anyone thought
we decided to call it a night and get
back to a hotel for the evening
and keep watching the results coming
through
[Music]
tonight o'clock eastern time the polls
have just closed in 13
states cbs news estimates that when all
the votes are counted donald trump will
win in west virginia
with arkansas likely to go his way
i mean it's suddenly looking extremely
close
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as the night progressed we started to
see people showing up with
body armor dressed all in black and full
faces covered we were able to sense a
change
it kind of looks like they're coming for
trouble we're hearing some
bangs and thumps and drums and whatever
and alex crawford is down there and can
tell us more about what's going on
uh alex dammit there's uh quite a few
hundred people they're setting off
fireworks
the atmosphere has entirely changed very
much
anti-trump but as the results have come
in
the atmosphere seems to have changed
quite dramatically
quite an ugly one right now much uglier
in sharp contrast to what we saw earlier
this group of antifa all clad in black
anti-fascists starting marching through
the streets
so we tagged on to their march to follow
that and see what happened
using black umbrellas to try and shield
their identity very anti-media
[Music]
[Applause]
the guys were not friendly towards us at
all
they were constantly jiving at us
sniping at us
from the sidelines seriously
they're just gonna let them walk it out
this woman is shining a light in in our
camera
oh two of them now to try and stop us
taking pictures
they have these flashlights and it's
like a strobe setting and they're just
holding it up
pointing it directly at my face and as
i'm filming
it's ruined the shot it just was
incredibly irritated by it
it's like what are you doing
okay don't touch him all you've got to
do is speak to it
don't shut that in my place
should we not get distracted
it's typical antifa's tactics when the
press are around
they keep saying that they don't want uh
their photos taken because they're
handed over to the police so they shine
lasers and torches into your face and
into the camera lenses
they were drawing attention to
themselves even though that's what they
were trying to avoid all right guys come
on
back off the sidewalk
we had to keep across the story
obviously so
at various points when we could we would
stop and
put the news on our phones or
ipads or go back to the hotel and see
get the tvs on so here we go
we're going to have to be patient we
feel good about where we are
we really do i'm here to tell you
tonight
we believe we're on track to win this
election keep the faith guys we're going
to win this
well thank you very much
this is a fraud on the american public
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
as you were saying derma as uh as
everyone seems to know by now
what looked perhaps like something where
we might know the answer
over the course of the night now it
feels like we are in for the long haul
and it may be
days who knows maybe even weeks before
we know for sure
who's won this election
[Music]
the antifa march the next night was um
was very different
predictably the riot police came in
and started to arrest them and started
to drag them off the street
these are scenes that you see in actual
conflict zones
you know not on the streets of american
cities
it was a bit scary when you first
arrived because there are people walking
around with machine guns which is always
completely amazes me um but they are
open carrying and they're allowed to
license well the writers actually been
declared
that's because there was uh violence on
property and they were busting that
stuff up
but the actual act of being on the
street
is allowed so although there's riot
police everywhere they've they've moved
off
um how long this goes on for it's it's
impossible to know it
at the end of the day is still a
democracy where people
who are eligible to vote can still vote
and so
to see the american flag being burnt
on the streets of america was a little
bit disturbing actually
they all sat down they'd been handcuffed
and were being
questioned by the police they're
unpleasant and that they're aggressive
in their nature
but you have to look at their kids most
of them
it was quite small scale it just seemed
a bit pointless
and certainly no either intimidation or
provocation from the authorities this
was actually just going in and smashing
up
windows for the sake of it we got the
impression
an awful lot of people they were
actually traumatized by everything that
had happened particularly in portland
but in other parts of the country as
well is that their fears were of what
might happen
next if trump was to win or if there was
no clear winner
[Music]
the election 2020 continues this
thursday morning joe biden moving closer
to the
270 electoral votes as the trump
campaign files multiple
lawsuits the problem was we were at a
slight disadvantage because of the time
zones the time zones meant that
london was several hours ahead of us
so they were making a lot of these
decisions whilst we were asleep
so the dreaded phone call of being woken
up by the news desk in london
which as a news team can happen at any
moment
so we were the team that was called in
having been to georgia
already i got a phone call from emily
and i can't remember what time it was
because she woke me up but she said
we've got 20 minutes to get out of here
um
pack up
we just literally raced to the airport
it's an internal flight but
we had minutes to spare
when we finally landed in georgia we had
three hours from landing
to being on air and we had to wrestle
together this
report in no time
stop china free hardcore
free hardcore there's quite a lot of
pressure on
us to do that to gather the material and
then for me to turn around and edit it
as well
well we're worried about the democrats
stealing the election lies in treachery
if you know something is wrong stand up
do you feel like it's gonna hit the fan
join your local militia
militias or what founded this country
this will go down
as a political revolution in terms of
just how many votes they've managed to
switch to the democratic party
but it also shows just how divided the
people of georgia
are and how representative that is of
the whole country
[Music]
[Applause]
the tight one oh tap tight
i've done that for a while you know
today was the day i fell in love with my
cameraman
because he edited a piece in 50 minutes
well done kev well done might have been
a bit more than that
now he's filming and crunching
we were rang again um at about five
o'clock in the morning
and uh asked if we could go to las vegas
okay we're leaving portland and we're on
our way to vegas there's six votes to
play for in nevada the
presidential elections getting really
really tight now
yeah planes i you know i like playing
travel i used to love playing travel
kovid has made it blinking awful
yeah not the healthiest
so is that a pringle an oreo and a
coffee
there weren't many choices
joe biden is leading nevada but by a
very slim margin right now
the uncounted ballads could sway this
race
in either direction i got to vegas
and it was it was exactly what i thought
it would be
actually it was pretty tacky and a bit
rough around the edges
so we're in las vegas just composter
gambling machines actually in a bit when
you get off the plane it's crazy
you go from news gathering and having
time to talk to people and filming and
getting a feel for the story
to suddenly needing to do lives and you
know
live after live after live after live
after live
really the pressure at this point is on
the correspondent
you know you're literally sitting for
hours you know just
waiting to do shot after shot off the
shot
a lot waiting around was a lot of
drinking coffee in
car parks audio books
press-ups it you do anything you can rip
because
you know it's they're long old days so
this is um our i can't remember
how many lives we've done today um this
vote count is like
the slowest vote count in the history of
hope count and
every now and again they release a data
drop but
um we're going to have a trump rally
here's your
probably they just made quite a lot of
noise
away from that fact
ultimately what we're doing is we're
coming out here as a community
and saying that we are worried that our
votes are not going to be counted
we are more we are growing more
distrustful
of the elections infrastructure because
we've voiced similar concerns since 16
and 18 and they've never been addressed
nobody was hostile to us
outside of the county office but
it's difficult to articulate how much
conspiracy theories have got a grip in
the u.s
and how many people believe them they
believe him
you know they believe him and they trust
in him and they trusted that what he was
saying was true
i do believe that this entire thing has
been set up to fail
it looks like positive denial plausible
deniability
is definitely something that they're
going to be able to fall back on
i've never seen so many mistakes and
i've never known
an operations professional who would
make that many mistakes
it's too obvious so do you want them to
stop counting now
they should they should we knew that the
trump was going to be making a statement
we will stop there because there is the
commander-in-chief
thank you very much let's listen in we
pulled off the live shots and i think we
got another burger
and we watched this statement in the car
and
um he completely trashed the election
if you count the legal votes i
easily win if you count the illegal
votes
they can try to steal the election from
us if you count the votes that came in
late
we're looking at them very strongly but
a lot of votes came in late
it was quite incredible quite incredible
the allegations
that he was making i have heard
countless times
but in places like afghanistan iraq
pakistan you know
various parts of syria i never thought
i'd hear
them from the mouth of the president of
america
so the president has just
comprehensively
attacked and said that the american
democratic process
is fraudulent well let's go uh to the
state of nevada
uh where joe biden has a narrow lead
i've
cannot quite believe what i was hearing
i can't imagine the damage that is being
done
by the president to the whole system in
the united states
and we're in a country where so many
people have weapons that have been out
on the streets already
it really is scary territory this i mean
that is possibly the most irresponsible
comment that uh or comments that this
president
has ever made and i it is somewhat
ironic uh adam
my career has involved me working in
countries run by dictators
and corrupt presidents who are going to
steal elections or simply rig the votes
alex just uh hearing from stuart ramsey
who's very experienced like you that he
fears ugliness possibly later on in
nevada how would you describe
how the mood in georgia and atlanta
where you are
the mood has been very subdued amongst
the democratic
supporters we haven't seen many of them
the people we
have seen outside the state farm arena
are
flag waving trump supporters who are
calling echoing their leaders words
calling it fraudulent saying they're
trying to steal the vote
saying that they're cheating whatever
happens over the next couple of years
journalists around the world are going
to be coping with this phenomenon that
he's
created of fake news i can't emphasize
how much danger that puts almost every
journalist in
there are still some states including
georgia where there haven't been
projected winners though biden is ahead
by more than 12 000 votes of the nearly
5 million that were cast in georgia
there are still laws and procedures that
must be followed before we can legally
say who gets george's 16 electoral votes
everyone was guessing when the eventual
call would be made
[Music]
sky news can now say that the next
president of the united states
is projected to be joe biden
and at that point we launched into
action
and then basically jumped in the car and
set off
gathering for a report that evening
you're not loud enough we got a new
president
there was this explosion of
excitement mixed with relief a black
woman is gonna be in the white house and
fight
[Applause]
it was like akin to toppling a dictator
really was wild celebrations
tooting of horns you know it's like that
in
zimbabwe when mugabe
[Music]
lost
the celebrations now happening across
the country and also right here in las
vegas you could hear
carr honking on the strip tonight as
people were waving american flags
well i'm stuck in the car which is
because i'm doing the driving
but um we're doing i believe we're doing
a story about
republican reaction to losing
[Music]
we went to get pictures of the trump
tower and
just as we were pulling up there we had
loads of horns honking
and then dominique spotted some biden
flags that were down and this was on the
main strip
in las vegas
for all the jubilation of the democrat
supporters very very pleased
with the biden victory you can't forget
that this was a really close election
here in nevada
there's an awful lot of trump fans still
who are very very angry
that is going to be the job providing to
try and get the country back together
[Music]
the trump fans were still there still
beeping their horns as well and still
saying stop the
stop account and were absolutely adamant
that
they would still overturn the election
we need to start over
and we need to make sure that the count
is legitimate because if anybody thinks
that this could possibly
have legitimate numbers it's completely
out of their mind because it's
impossible tens of millions of absentee
ballots
they got their news from some pretty
unreliable
strange sources if there's an
investigation carried out
it goes to the courts and it agreed
and the courts listen to the objections
will you accept the result
give the courts if you have really no no
other decision
but i know one thing that god has the
same control
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome the vice president-elect
of the united states of america
[Applause]
we've been scrambling all day to get the
package out
and then do lives through the night
and we really wanted to get back and
sit down and watch the speeches from
kamala harris and
joe biden that evening protecting
our democracy takes struggle
it takes sacrifice but there is
joy in it and there is progress
because we the people have
the power to build a better future
i don't think there can be many women
who wouldn't have been affected by
her speech who know the challenges that
she
must have faced and then on top of that
she's a person of color
but while i may be the first woman in
this office
i will not be the last
oh that was a fantastic speech i pledge
to be a president
who seeks not to divide but unify
who doesn't see red states of blue
states only sees the united states
[Music]
[Applause]
we will never give up we will never
concede it doesn't happen
you don't concede with his theft
involved
our country has had enough we will not
take it anymore and that's what this is
all about
covering the us election it was this
crazy roller coaster with all these
twists and turns
and it still feels like america's on
that roller coaster
and no one really knows where the next
twist is gonna come but there will be
[Music]
[Music]
one
president trump simply refuses to play
by the norms that one expects from the
election
the chair declares the joint session
dissolved
he's going to have his work cut out
because the far left and the far right
in the united states
are further than probably anyone could
imagine they would be
i'm finished making sense
it's the same old story same old story
what if i say